hello freak [ __ ] they did not want oh
that's funny
well you know a lot of boxing people
won't like I was saying before they want
to defend boxing they want you know they
want to be on Team boxing and honestly I
played a part of that a little bit when
I had this thing with Luda Bella's right
he's very good now by the way well I
felt like it was pretty easy yeah he
wasn't making for a good argument the
other problem is I mean you know if I
really went to war with someone I said
yeah I got that guy it was a terrible
argument and I'm a fan like that's the
dumpster I'm a fan of boxing like and I
probably know a lot I bet if he and I
sat down and we just started talking
about classic fights Hagler Hearns you
know Sugar Ray Leonard Roberta Durant
like he would realize like really quick
I'm a legit boxing fan I [ __ ] love
boxing how many rounds did Hagler Hearns
go is that three yes yes draw a third
Hagler oh no I don't know he had that
fight with Mayweather though where
Mayweather just Mayweather did a genius
thing first of all I made him cut a lot
of weight let him get down to 152
drained him up a little bit and then you
know he caught him before he reached the
level that he's at now like when he
fought Amir Khan
America he [ __ ] Aamir Khan up dude
with a haymaker of a right hand and you
know when he when he landed that bomb
and put Amir Khan to sleep you got to go
okay this is a guy that's now at the
[ __ ] peak of his game so when he
fought Mayweather Mayweather caught him
all right when he was getting into it
you know right when he was coming up and
that Mayweather fight I think took him
over the top when you fight a guy that's
a slick and it's talented it [ __ ]
fast and the timing that Mayweather has
and realize like there's levels to this
thing is golovkin fighting it the way he
normally fights out yes yes is his
weight man he's the king
this guy's a beast I know guys behind
look exactly like him too
the good thing about this fight is
what's interesting is gonna go Lufkin
some experts believe that he might be
slipping slightly and Canelo is coming
up and the idea is that a year ago
golovkin what a [ __ ] hello up this is
what a lot of people believe but now
Canelo's better and golovkin might have
faded a little bit what's the age
difference
think golovkin is he's older for sure
but I think he's 35 see if you could
find that young Jamie I want to say he's
35 or 36 well Kim is what 34 I think
he's on Thursday 35 okay so yeah so
that's like if unless he's Juicin that's
the last of the squeeze eight years yeah
when you're around no but I mean when
you're around 35 like that's when the
decline happens to almost everybody 36
it slips 37 slips more 39 40 very rarely
see a 40 year old champion it's not on
the sauce yeah I mean that way that's
why Randy Couture was such an amazing I
mean yeah it's really what Bernard
Hopkins was the Mach Jesus yeah he
wanted to his 50s yeah and he still was
out boxing world-class fighters and
dropping them you know I mean he got
[ __ ] up by Joe Smith but Joe Smith is
a mom sighs his final fight we get knock
through the ring yeah Harry how old is
he no 52 or 53 and he was 50 when he
last fought but he was 51 or 52 and his
brain is private um well he's perfectly
coherent like there's the I don't know
how here we go round one ladies and
gentlemen Eddie Bravo prediction I'm
gonna go with the Mexican dude you got
to go with your people
Norton I got to go with golovkin have to
yeah okay white absolutely I feel like
either one of these [ __ ] could
shock there's Kazakhstan considered
white well yeah I mean it's definitely
white if you go to a black neighborhood
and try to say the n-word yep that's all
you need to know is it are you white
well can you get away with being in a
black neighborhood and using the end
yeah that type of credibility or do not
yeah if you're Wesley Snipes dark you
can get away with using it anywhere in
the world
right sure so Canelo's white Canelo is
actually Mexican but he's got red
[ __ ] hair it's crazy freckles but if
a Kazakhstan is considered white then
why wouldn't Canelo be considered white
but he is white for sure I mean he's
Russian or you know part of the Soviet
the Soviet Union
that's right China well you know a lot
of these people have [ __ ]
a lot of these people right there well
no it's like an Asian but it's um
that's Genghis Khan I mean Genghis Khan
they I think they said some insane
number like five percent of all the men
in Asia or all the people in Asia have
Genghis Khan's genes Jesus he's dumping
loads all over the place everybody and
killed everyone killed like you know
they don't even know how many millions
but somewhere between 20 and 70 million
people died directly by his hand
you know what his daughter was now which
one Chaka Chaka Khan I met her in a
falafel place in New York me and Godfrey
chased her down the street and Randy oh
my god love conspired in this one in 200
of the whole population in the world is
directly descended from Genghis Khan
look at that oh my god what years was he
was he alive it was like the 1200
basically a hundred percent of China
yeah whoa dude this is a great fight huh
golovkin just double jab him ooh that's
a strong jab that might be a big factor
he's used that jab before on guys and
and shocked them and out [ __ ] out boxed
him
Lemieux he did that with he came out and
started popping him with the jab and a
lot of people didn't expect that he can
outbox his [ __ ] out of people you caught
him yeah okay
Oh block though those nothing's happen
in there those are getting blocked the
jab is what you got to keep an eye on
see in order counter right hand of
Canelo is it a lot bigger whoo triple G
yeah he's bigger he's taller see how
that wire keeps Landon his face is
[ __ ] up and it's the first round he's
getting lit up with that straight jab
he's got a two he shaded a lot well he
gets angry at people and starts talking
[ __ ] to him and he puts his hands down
lets them punch him in the face
when he was breaking this one dude down
as he was breaking him down he put his
hands down started walking towards the
maleta guy punch him just move his hands
slightly and then [ __ ] digs in on him
is this a mean guy man how lankan yeah
this is a psychology that amazing though
when you drop your hands a lot of times
guys won't react immediately convinces
the schoolyard humiliation of a guy
doing that and you missing yeah it's
really weird to watch professional
fighters not always just go right in
with it and let me help you out with
that there's also reason when you drop
your hands you don't know where the
punches are coming from it's a different
thing like it's very tricky when someone
drops their hands you have to be very
careful because things can come from
anywhere it's one of the reasons why
Tommy Hearns when he jabbed he kept his
hand down here and hop it up in your
face it's you don't see it as much you
don't see it it's quick if someone's
standing right here and you see this and
you see that you see the hands a little
bit more there it's a traditional
pattern that you understand what someone
has their hands down low and they start
running their head shift can come wild
from all over the place how many of you
prepare cards has triple G headline only
a few he's been mostly like an HBO
fighter because his his pay-per-views
didn't sell well like one of them only
soul Gennady golovkin I forget it we
fought but he was like 150,000 buys it's
unfortunate because he's [ __ ] mm like
marvelous in there I mean this guy's he
beat Kell Brook ko Brooks very good and
he broke him down white guy yeah no he's
a black guy from England really bad ass
world champion at a lighter weight he
was world champ but I believe at
welterweight and he came up oh look at
this
Cal I don't like all that that's a
little wasted energy right there a
little too much emotion he I mean he
liked rooster him got behind that's a
lot of energy just blew there that
happened a lot too during encounter uh
I'm a with a lot I think that was
different though you know yeah these
guys are way more identical in terms of
skill and career but I'm seeing golovkin
get the better of these exchanges well
they just showed you both jabbed each
other at the same time stiff you know
the age could really be a factor you
know Canelo so never really taking a
beating he only had one fight City loss
and that was that fight with Mayweather
and he really didn't get beat up and
that fight he just got out boxed was
that a decision yeah unanimous clear
Mayweather just showed him what's up but
he didn't knock him out you know what I
mean it's like
Canelo's beating the [ __ ] out of some
really good fighters
he's super dangerous puncher and
golovkin has been in way more Wars than
Canal Canelo has Canelo's figured out a
way to avoid Wars and just put it on
people it's just [ __ ] really good man
this is for boxing this is like as good
as a cat yes because Canelo still
getting better you know oh that's a
sweet job I mean he's 27 now and this
fight is gonna make him better too you
know he's only 27
golovkin if Cannell managed to KO him
and he's 35 could be the end you know or
at least the beginning of the end he's
not 25 but Canelo almost is and part of
the appeal is that he's 37 I know
there's something about undefeated
fighter like those 3 G's on his belt
that's dope
well he's undefeated for a reason man
he's a [ __ ] mask yeah Gucci should
sponsor him just what we want to hear
jeez
where the Freemasons just the other one
put over your day just put put our g's
up top and then your G over the dick you
blowed the watch company sponsored his
dick look is that funny that people care
about that like yeah like that the UFC
what like we didn't want that a lot of
people felt felt like you they see too
much of that on boxer shorts it bothers
them I don't even notice it I didn't
even help with sales or does it get into
your psyche you don't even realize it's
in there it's good question I remember
back in the day cigarette companies used
to sponsor fighters like boxers used to
have cigarette companies on their shorts
forget who did that you know what it
might have been my orga did who [ __ ] had
a cigarette company sponsored them
cigarette company sponsored boxers you
ever see the old were they were sponsors
of cartoons and they would show Fred
smokey a Winston like they would have
like [ __ ] uh what's that I hate that
show the Flintstones
you hate the fluence I've [ __ ] that
makes me sick despise Fred Flintstone
why I don't know I just always hated
them why so it's a weird one I'm not a
big cartoon driver that like until you
look at that left hook the body son whoa
boom golovkin with a crisp straight
right this is as good as it gets for
boxing man it really is you know you got
a guy in golovkin undefeated 35 no been
blasting everybody wanting that big
fight and then killing a little Alvarez
this proud superstar steps up wants his
fight and just daylight they both call
each other out they both want I mean
Canales always said he wanted to fight
the very best he's bleeding glove gun it
looks like he's behind it Wow goddamn go
off khun's good god damn he's good he
landed some shots there man
whoo that was an interesting combination
the way through the left hook and then
threw it again a surprising left hook
the second left took in particular he's
forcing this kid to box with them I mean
to slug with him that's his style of
fight Canelo is a really good counter
striker and what's what's going on here
now is golovkin is just really coming to
him and Canelo's this is like a perfect
fight in a lot of ways this is like the
kind of fight you would hope but this
Canelo want to stand there with him and
trade punches well he wants a counter
strike but I mean golovkin is gonna come
towards him so he has his opportunities
I mean it's it's a brilliant fight like
as far as like what you know
stylistically it's perfect has has
golovkin ever even really been in
trouble in a fight not really he's been
punched a lot though never been dropped
no I don't believe so I've never even
seen him like stunned he did have a
really good fight in his last fight
can you put golovkin's record ups like
remember homeboys name he's had a couple
of very good fights where you know
people are coming to him very you know
enthusiasm was that last fight he fought
Sherman was less I don't I
Daniel Dan Jacob Daniel Jacobs is the
one that's that guy that was a really
close fight awesome awesome fight but it
was unanimous decision for Gennady
golovkin but Daniel Jacobs is [ __ ]
for real white guy black Kaka he's super
good so it was like it was a big win and
you know everybody could tell watching
the fight that Jacobs is super legit he
knew
coming in but so even though he didn't
knock him out it's still he's still one
yeah Canelo's fierce fierce both guys
are fierce oh that left hooks to the
body work and hello they're both so good
man oh that uppercut damn see and
they're the other thing you got to think
of is age man the reality of age 35 with
some Wars behind on versus 27 with
really no wars just smashing a lot of
people real good trainers when the same
trainer since he was a kid what are you
showing me Jamie what's going on is that
the UFC oh my god you're amazing how can
we can't put it on that TV oh we got to
fix that
who would these guys fighting arm
triangle great gorgeou let's be Jason
well folks we are we should be on
Twitter at the same time we should be
periscope I don't use any of those live
I want to know why like my face I just
yeah I know it's supposed to help but I
just can't do it
yeah I'm just it sometimes it's too much
he keeps going back to the arm triangle
he lost it last time yeah likes it oh no
he lost against look he's gonna under
jack it again you go right back to it
easy honest he goes right back to it
look at that [ __ ] you could tell you
know I knew who's gonna do it cuz he's
so good there's no way he's gonna he's
gonna wear him out he's got to keep him
in the chopping that's right he's got to
not try to finish him just keep him in
the chopping block what do you think of
that way of defending that was a nice
way Dan when you grab you know that's
the weed and they're like doing it the
way he's doing it oh he's gone he's gone
it's over yeah Pat what was that what uh
with dos Anjos finished off Neil Magny
with yes he did yeah smushed him round
four here we go
this is to a DD having the FC play here
to perfect time because you don't you
rarely see an under Jack battle in the
UFC like that yeah that was a battle he
tried it three different times you
rarely see that you don't ever see that
that's Gregor little SP he's he's
[ __ ] beast man
Gregor Gillespie yeah that's a bad
[ __ ] like that he's at least has
some good mount strategies he wasn't
trying to beat him up he was trying to
finish it you shot to the body
oh man Canelo just hit him with a hard
left hook to the body and go let's see
if they show that these guys are going
at it man this is crazy
this is a [ __ ] war man I mean like
we're watching like an all-time classic
boxing war right now oh look at that jab
that hit looks like I missed under him
huh popped him fast ooh
hmm Eddie Bravo would you be watching
this if it wasn't for us yes because
he's Mexican ah did you know was gonna
start at 8 they always start around 8:00
8:30 well I'm not eventually they
started like 9:00 they decided to start
this one early okay just to make sure
that people in the East Coast look at Oh
golovkin with that jab you think that
was the thinking to like let's make sure
people in New York and Jersey and
Florida can order this yeah for sure
that's what oh dude ooh this is
distracting [ __ ] he just did that thing
by where he dropped his arms a little
bit - yeah it's boxing him up he shook
his head as soon as they shake their
head no that means yes yeah does that
ever mean the guy isn't hurt when he
shakes because why would you tell him
you didn't hurt you're not hurt well it
does kind of like you ain't got [ __ ] you
could say got a guy but the problem is
when someone actually hits you and
really dings you and then you do it like
never
well maybe the know is saying no you
didn't knock me down not this time maybe
that's what he means maybe it doesn't
seem like it most mostly what it seems
like that didn't hurt like that ain't
[ __ ] he didn't get me no one ever says
you didn't knock me down
yeah except in like a Jake LaMotta movie
that was exactly a very close up on the
ring he's trying to [ __ ] you jab in that
counter right together these guys are so
well matched whoo look at that tight
left hook by triple G he's hurt triple G
no Canelo you think so yeah
what makes you say that because he keeps
going backwards into the ropes a body
shot that you were talking about right
when that landed he looked at his eyes
he went oh [ __ ] you might be right
might be right I keep forgetting these
are three minute rounds and no they're
weird right yeah you get into it you
like I'll [ __ ] the belt you know what's
interesting about that it's easier to go
five minutes boxing than it is to go
three minutes of wrestling yeah this UFC
is like five minute rounds and boxing is
three minute rounds they just got used
to it
but one thing though is if you give a
short around there is a good argument
for a shorter route
that argument is guys can go faster and
harder in three minutes than they can in
five because they have to conserve
themselves right do you feel like boxing
over the last year is making a comeback
or never sure okay I think boxing is in
a good place right it's making a little
comeback yeah and it might have
something to do with the fact that
there's a rivalry going on between UFC
and boxing like what sport is better
yeah I think it's bringing more
attention to boxing you know by the UFC
fans they're paying attention to boxing
because there's this debate argument
maybe the UFC doesn't auxin up
well it's also boxing's in a real good
place right now there's so many good
fighters mishchenko I mean these two
gentlemen where do you really do a three
minute round UFC I mean with jiu-jitsu
and all that just say you couldn't work
what I would think is maybe a five
minute round a box and be kind of
interesting but I think they're doing it
right honestly because I think you know
you could go hard and fast for three
minutes and maybe it'll ensure a faster
pace for the majority of the fight then
if you made guys fight five-minute
rounds how often did they give out ten
eight rounds in boxing quite when guys
get dropped quite a bit it's pretty
common
it was uncommon for a long time in MMA
but it's more common now while those
good head movement to everybody Canelo I
feel that a rule changes right yeah can
now avoid it most of that he's good
really good defense air his defense is
tight good movement oh there's a good
right hand of the body it's just like to
get to this level soaks is this what's
exciting about this fight is that to get
to this level there's so much [ __ ] you
got to go through it's so rare that a
guy comes out this good you know but
there's so few of them that even rarely
get two of them finally fighting yeah
like this who else were the top
pay-per-view boxers you're looking at it
right in this yeah what Floyd's retired
Manny Pacquiao is not drawing the
numbers he used to and his last fight he
fought he lost to like a schoolteacher
you know his time is basically done to
fight that was Australia what about in
the heavyweight division no pay-per-view
there well Anthony Joshua's a huge star
in London in England and probably in
Europe in the UK in America he's a big
star with boxing fans but sort of like
how triple G's a big star with boxing
fans Canelo is a huge star with actual
Mexicans like across the board and maybe
you could say that about Anthony Joshua
with England I'd you know I'm not in
England could very well be this oh look
at that right hand over the top he said
no he said no oh I don't know about
anything boxing needs to do to keep the
upward it's hard it's just hard you got
guys like Terence Crawford he's a bad
[ __ ]
he got lomachenko you've got some good
fighters you've got Andre Ward is one of
the best in the world the UFC light or
the boxing light heavyweight champion
was also the US gold medalist in boxing
he's a beast I think we got to do is
give people the fights that they want
not make them wait for it for two years
and three years that's easier said than
done
oh absolutely it's what helped the UFC I
think so much do that and they're
shaking their hands at each other oh
this is crazy
Canelo swinging some shots he's throwing
them hard Matt oh oh
guard lovely glove get out a little bit
maybe glove again how do you say it come
on Kim Chi love again kaluf Caen oh this
is a good fight Oh dropped his hands
you're popular jacking Cologne on the
back of his pants be June by June or
pajamas yeah that's a cologne this guy
Norman used to wear it in department
store I worked in the newsroom for
stealing here we smelled good oh that's
hilarious the smells yeah he smelled
grams like what is it he's like by June
people are weird with their [ __ ]
colognes right yeah I have a whole
[ __ ] shelf Oldham do you yeah I just
I don't know why I like him it's
overcompensation I think I used to
where's your car oh god yeah it was
great that was like [ __ ] that was
like Guido stuff in like like 1988 1990
who taught you how to wear it get laid
yeah girls like cologne capezios yeah I
like it
for some reason where I love it you
gotta wear it anyway what they're like I
don't like a girl to wear perfume at all
like I really don't like I like natural
yeah I like the fruity smell
like the the sweet look at this perfumes
Oh son you know I don't like any my
wanted to smell like a [ __ ] gorilla
Canelo shook his head with that that was
a bomb that he got hit with it graved
them it's weird
male perfume it's weird that we accept
that you know oh look at that right hand
damn dude the love kids pouring it on Oh
golovkin is landing some shots man the
sixth round this is just the sixth round
I don't know
Oh Canelo's fired back that's a hard
shot to the body
you heard him to the arty he went back
to it golovkin is in trouble he's hurt
to the body he knows it yeah man he does
know it he hit him with the right hand
look at he's landing yeah no oh [ __ ]
what a turnaround it's so hard to
recover from that liver shot - you got
to keep moving but your diminished
you've been hitting the liver Jim I know
you've had a lot of guys leg kick you
and choke you I don't think anyone's
ever purposely punched me in the liver
I've had a lot of things done they're
all unpleasant but they say that's a
pretty bad one it's horrible and to fact
I'm pretty sure that happened just now a
Gennady golovkin and you could barely
tell watching him fight oh that hit in
the chest they're a little high who was
a good fight it's so back and forth yeah
I punched a guy in the liver in the
fourth grade then this [ __ ] yeah you got
to work any techniques on the fourth
grade means you were nine are you sure
you actually hit the liver totally bro
crushed it it's a horrible thing to kick
well people get a liver needle liver
might be the worst that's one of the
worst need to deliver is horrifying
that's Ronda Rousey was so good at that
she would tie girls up in that judo
clinch and then just knee the [ __ ] out
of their body was ruthless cuz she was
so good at like a
her body control she could tie you up so
well from judo Hogan I'll off you want
the right hand of the body she would
just get a hold of girls and then she
started [ __ ] nuking him with knees to
the body she did that Sara McMann god
damn this is good yeah this is really so
tense right like anything can happen
here fortunes can change the drop of a
hat
whoo Canelo is firing him huh Oh 4449
244 power punches god damn it that is so
insane favor of Koloff is Ronda coming
back you think I don't think she's gonna
wrestling I think it's over yeah I think
so I don't think she wants to do it
anymore you know for whatever reason you
could break that down psychologically
all day you know Matt Sarah had a great
line that I never forgot he said a long
time ago that everybody likes to be the
hammer oh yeah but nobody wants to be
the nail yeah there's always if you're
the nail can you come back yeah and
there's always gonna be finders out
there that you can't take down and
you're gonna be forced to stand sure and
the level of striking right now with the
girls is at an all-time high and if you
ain't top on top of your striking even
if you get really good it's still
Russian roulette
these girls are some of the like
Shevchenko and Amanda Nunez yes you know
so Dane we can't take the person down
you have to strike and then it becomes a
kickboxing battle how good is your
kickboxing boxing battle you hope and
pray that something goes along and you
get it to the ground hey you know what
Rhonda has good striking it's not
terrible but even if it was great
there's a lot of great strikers out
there so at the end of the day you're
gonna be forced to win a kickboxing
tournament at the very top it's gonna be
very hard she didn't wrestle her whole
life she's doing judo at an Olympic
level yeah she has great takedowns she
was able to ragdoll most of her
opponents but right now man it's gonna
be very hard for her to take these girls
down right now she's gonna be forced to
strike so then it becomes you know she
could win some she could lose some how
many look did she beat that or strikers
as good as Holly Holm
none none of them were as good as her
the only one who was closest cat Zingano
and she caught cat really earlier at the
first round right yeah with an armbar
cat just charged at her and got caught
with an armbar yeah I think Rhonda said
I think cat deserve better like she she
knew that that was just a kind of a
fluke you know what cat said that the
reason why she charged at her like that
is cuz like she took a furious beating
in that Amanda Nunez fight she won the
fight but she got [ __ ] up in that
first round like real bad and she's like
I didn't want to go through that again
right she was I just want to charge at
her and get a hold of her I'm such an if
Ronda Rousey decided to on the girl she
couldn't throw or take down plan B is
that flying guard pole she had the guard
for it she has an amazing guard mazing
arm bar from the guard her plan should
have been in my opinion to get the fight
to the ground try to be on top try to
use your judo if that didn't work we
have to go to pole and guard Roger with
someone like a man Nunez is that's not
going to happen I think you're gonna get
eaten up at punches when you try to get
close Amanda's got some yeah you got his
arms in order to pull guard you got you
got to pull off a legit shot to get that
to react to get them to sprawl and
that's when you pull guard when you're
under him and they sprawl you time it
perfect it's a it's a technique it's
just like a takedown regards amazing
just like in that fight where that surge
Omar I he was on his back hurt and and
his opponent wouldn't get on top of this
let's pay attention to this cuz some
[ __ ] has happening here
golovkin cracked him we're still gonna
be able to watch the rock hold fight -
oh so exciting
yeah it's only 8:30 this fights nuts man
he's really impressive off the ropes too
golovkin I know Alvarez
oh yeah well he's impressive everywhere
they both are I mean these are two legit
world champions that's why this is so
exciting I haven't seen get off golfing
on the road much at all this fight no
because he's been taking it to Canelo
and that's his style and when that's
what's so interesting about this setup
is that everybody knew that Canelo is a
really good counter puncher I just got
really good timing he just seems a bit
too small Canelo yeah that Jeff really
there's a size difference man there's
definitely a size difference but he's
thick you know I just think frame wise I
think you're right but I think the money
is where he's at you know I mean I think
this fight is a big big money fight
don't know how many good fights there
are for him at 54 what big names there
are I think he struggles to make that
way too who gloved in know Canelo I
think he struggles even to make 60 and
this is a what this is 60 I think 154 is
a real struggle for them because that's
what Mayweather got them down to 150 -
Mayweather is so smart it was a little
bit more weight we'll talk a little more
way yes a little more weight and the
thing about Conor like what he did to
Connor very smart - which was just make
him fight make him work get him get him
tired and then start putting it to him
to start piling it up wearing him out
piling it out wearing him out yeah when
you saw me with her unloading you're
like oh yeah that's right yeah he's
[ __ ] Floyd Mayweather
he's one of if not the best boxer ever
and Connor's did catch him with a couple
things uh loo that jab son Oh No HBO
paper you went blank
good there oh they all panic imagine
let's see what do you think here he's
definitely losing the rounds but he's
like he's putting up a good fight so I'm
thinking I was losing oh yeah yeah he's
got 19 worst headshots for
golovkin yeah they have golovkin ahead
three to three brought three points 65
to 68 but the thing is it looks like
golovkin
trying to put him away he's not just
content to beat him he's putting massive
pressure on him here you know I mean and
you saw Canella take a big deep breath
and as we get into the 8 9 10 11 12
Canella fades a little he fades a little
he throws hard power shots and I know he
keeps working hard on his conditioning
and he works harder than anybody but
it's just that style is exhausting
well good plus galovski wants to put him
away because he hears people talking
about his age too
I mean you know everyone say is he does
he have it anymore just blown down yeah
that's the consensus Oh shots to the
body good shots the body by Canelo he
might have hurt him again he might have
hurt him again to the body
golovkin is not firing out up see Oh
catching his breath yeah you got a grip
to the body dude this is a good fight
this fight if every boxing match was
like this boxing would be huge the thing
that's genius about Mayweather is he
managed to never be in one of these yeah
he really did avoid everything did all
of it he never got beat up he only got
hit clean like seven times eight times
this whole career and he's made the most
money made way more than anybody else
combined like double or triple at least
right oh yeah I mean he's for sure the
number one moneymaker ever Oh without a
doubt yeah close this put him to a
billionaire category in the neighborhood
you know who knows exactly what the deal
is and but dude they got 6.25 something
million paper views
that's insane I wonder what he's saving
up for I wonder what he does no taxes
too I think he owes money to note a
little bit before this fight but he
might buy a basketball team oh look at
that uppercut the big thing is him not
going too crazy and spending it all and
blowing it all I think they have my
mansions and [ __ ] all sorts of Rolls
Royces but well you know when he got
quality cars
he was like way deep in the tacks oh
nice uppercut by Canelo he was
definitely like in big tax trouble
before we got bailed out with a fight in
the past
you think they rematch I think they
rematch they should why not I think
Connor would have to beat somebody good
in a boxing match and he would also have
to have a real training camp I think I
think boxing is over for Conor oh I
don't think so one more fight like that
because people will buy it now if this
kind of went to the 10th round he got
fatigued is so emotive people to buy it
yeah I mean look he he went the very
first fight against the greatest hour
there's so many bits to bag you're right
that's right fight you're right there's
that too but the thing is if there's a
legit big fight like say if Canelo
Alvarez
steps up and says that he wants to fight
Conor McGregor
[Laughter]
I think Conor maybe realize you got it
specialized well absolutely you can't do
both especially the difference between
Canelo and Floyd Floyd was just a
brilliant boxer
Canelo's a murderous puncher and he'll
[ __ ] you up he'll hurt you there's also
a promotional difference to Conor and
Floyd are pretty much they're very
similar guys and they both understood
what they were doing promotion wise I
don't know if Canelo is that guy well
he's not gonna promote it that way but
he's got all ooh that uppercut that's
his genius it's he's got the support of
the American people or does love Ginn vs
McGregor oh look at that uppercut
I don't know if I Gregory take that
fight no that's not a good fight for him
either
neither Canelo or golovkin is a good
fight for him it's a terrible fight for
him those guys are different they're
durable they're this you know I click it
with the way these guys fight especially
with this is how golovkin fights every
fight I bring big drama show that's what
he calls it dude
I mean this is one of those fights we're
gonna be looking back on someday look at
those shot Abomasnow
this is one of those fights that we're
gonna look back on and go you remember
when we watch that [ __ ] fight holy
[ __ ] look at that he just shook his head
on him
golovkin is putting tremendous pressure
on him he's trying to break him
yeah he's keeping him against the ropes
for 80% of the fight it's not just that
like it's a pace that he's fighting at
he's trying to make him wither he sees
something you think he's he's invading
yeah he sees him trying to catch some
breaks he's still super dangerous but
golovkin catches he's seeing Canelo
trying to catch his breath and that's he
he splayed out on the seat in between
rounds feet we're all out yeah see if I
if I know this and I don't know that
much about boxing I know that Canelo has
what people think of as an endurance
problem and it's not you know it's not a
big mystery he just kind of fades a
little bit who we just got tagged he
just get tagged
he might get [ __ ] oh it's not that he
doesn't work hard it's just like his
style is just so explosive and he's got
so much muscle that he carries around
that style requires you to being [ __ ]
sensational shape well it does it does
it mean anything that is a counter
puncher because they're always getting
hit first so you got to take a little
bit more to know not necessarily his
defense is outstanding look at that look
how good he ducked under that right hand
his defense is amazing it's just like
he's never been hit like this before and
not with a guy like golovkin it's just
putting it to him he's been hit by a guy
like Floyd who just caught him with good
clean scoring shots snapped his head
back a couple of times but nothing like
but like a mule kicking in the face this
is a different thing because golovkin is
trying to break him he's not just trying
to win he's putting himself in danger
he's putting himself in danger to prove
that he's the best and that's a
different thing that's a different kind
of person with he's not making the kind
of money that these guys are making he's
hungry as [ __ ] see that uppercut you Oh
baby and again he's not making the kind
of like superstar money that he just saw
Conner and Floyd make and the only way
that he can make it is to being big
drama show and so he's just coming for
death once again for this fight
who knows and I think it's probably
depending upon the pay-per-view sales
yeah I literally have no scale for what
these guys make I have no clue millions
Canelo is a superstar he's gonna sell I
mean he would sell [ __ ] in a million
pay-per-view he's fighting the uber
driver and I'm not joking oh so he's a
bigger draw than Koloff Canelo yeah and
I was getting 5g triple G's getting
three nice two million more know if you
know how famous he is it makes sense
yeah he's huge like that guy goes Viva
Mexico and everybody [ __ ] roof almost
falls off I'll tell you what man
Mexicans and Irish that they make you
reconsider the idea patriotism very very
proud people like when you hear the
Irish people that we're in town in Vegas
when Connors fighting you ever see that
video of Mandalay Bay the whole Mandalay
Bay which the fight wasn't even there
okay the whole Mandalay Bay field I mean
to where you couldn't walk with Irish
people and they're all singing together
yeah it was insane and that wasn't even
where the fight was being held we saw
that the garden outside in November it
was [ __ ] I was with Matt Serra's
freezing outside these maniacs have
short-sleeved shirts and tank tops no
yeah didn't we walk to the garden
together we walked there to they'll be
coming leaving the guard it was freezing
that night yeah
that's right to his protest in front of
trumps apartment yeah that's right how
fun was that it was awesome we had a
walk Little Jimmy me and cam and weren't
you there young James was Tony there too
Brendon mischief-maker was there look at
that
poof oh oh god damn look at those that
left to the body that right over the top
holy [ __ ] what a fight this is but we
had a walk because there were so many
people protesting Trump always done him
he's not hurt go up got hurt he stumbled
Oh Canelo hit him with something oh look
at that jab oh my goodness
I thought again oh my god this is my Mac
this is a [ __ ] fight and this is the
10th round kids oh my god this is
amazing every hole yeah pull them apart
oh my god no these guys are going for
blood
golovkin is a [ __ ] savage man savage
he's kind of like 82% Genghis Khan bud
right if you had a guess you're right
the rats a good point the ref is not
stepping on she hasn't had a chance and
there's no need to this is a war yeah
especially the way Koloff can fights man
what a pace he puts on you you just
don't get a chance to breathe he's just
on you like he stays in a phone booth no
matter what and there's no breaks he
pops a jab you stepped back you right
back on yeah look at this he's just
right back on them constantly look at
this pressure right hand but you gotta
understand how terrifying this is when
you're fighting a guy like this that
doesn't get tired continues to push on
you and like that's why Canelo has to
take some breaks yeah he's not just
trying to get out of his way he doesn't
really want to be up against the ropes
like this he has to fight like this he
really doesn't have the energy to just
meet him in the center and go kablooey
at each other
so golovkin's pressure and constant
forward movement that's a big factor
here he's controlling where this fight
takes place another weapon
yeah it's ring generalship he's
completely controlling where the fight
takes place and he's showing much more
desire to win he's trying to stop Canelo
Canelo's trying to catch golovkin as
he's trying to stop him there's two very
different things happening here doesn't
mean the canal can't still put the
lights out on him but which way more
impressive is what golovkin's doing he's
just swarming a man and could see canal
grabs him after that see that that's
right he throws that shot that he grabs
him it's cuz he's wilting Luci his legs
just keep out there dude he's wilting he
is he's getting [ __ ] up he could still
come back hard because he's a [ __ ]
animal and he's a world champion but the
bottom line is he's starting to fade
we're in the 10th round
this shit's getting weird clear that he
still got some good head movement I'll
tell you that that was nice the car
is tremendous for edible tremendous
golovkin scardiest will go up against
another big bear guy is it yes he is
what's a big bear guy goes to Big Bear
to Train same as el Cucuy Tony's a
savage dude I've watched that guy train
for six hours straight Tony Ferguson his
cardio is [ __ ] through the roof of the
roof
he's an animation see the [ __ ] we're
doing up there crazy crazy she loved Big
Bear man said peaceful up there it's
cool what are you doing just one you
could work out there at a very high
altitude low oxygen content in the air
they say Eddie honestly the best thing
to do is not to train up there they say
the best thing to do is live up there
and to Train like down like to go down
to like sea level like drive an hour go
down a sea level train there and then go
do everything else up up top because
your body will adapt because the
altitude especially when you're sleeping
up there but you'll have more work
output you'll get more work in with your
body and slowly yeah what do I know
I'm not a scientist sign dude Tony don't
need more work there Tony goes forever
no I'm sure but I mean he could be even
better that's what I'm saying I just
think that that's what the science is I
mean it doesn't mean anything
Tony's obviously adapted to Big Bear
well [ __ ] that's such a good fight man
such a good fight Kevin Lee yeah so
Charlie yeah it's gonna be great Kevin
Lee is it is a serious threat you know
he's not taking him lightly very serious
threat there but very serious look at
their opponents Tony's been through some
you know he [ __ ] up Edson Barboza
Josh Thompson Raphael de zhonya's those
are big names big giant fine dos Anjos
Juan was very [ __ ] impressive very
impressive
that was a incredibly impressive fight
and then the other one that was really
impressive to me was the barboza fight
cuz Barboza stand up his top of the food
chain
you know and Tony was cracking him and
then finished him in a crazy bloodied
arse it wasn't all bloody and everything
on that Darce
yep yep and etson Barbosa is considered
probably top three most dangerous
strikers in the UFC oh yeah that guy
will light you up with wheel cakes head
carries
he's so fast he's so powerful he has the
first wheel kick ko in the UFC you know
in the highlight you could see
Ari Shaffir in the background going like
this yeah like as he gets hit and
cracked Terry he hits Terry Adam with
this crazy wheel kick is the first wheel
kick ko in the UFC and it was the
perfect one why it Aldo stock it seemed
like Aldo I noticed it in the Frankie
Edgar fight really stopped kicking or
throws a lot less is he huh good
question it's a very good question it
could be because he's got injuries that
don't allow him a kick anymore it could
be that it's easier for guys to take him
down when he kicks you'd have to talk to
him I'd like to talk to him good but he
didn't use it very much a max Holloway
but if you go back to like the Uriah
favor fight it was like his biggest
weapon yeah but I noticed against Frank
Yeager he's not throwing a lot of kids
yeah I wondered why I thought Frankie
was probably trying to time those kicks
in the rematch that made total sense to
me what didn't make sense is how he
didn't use him that much against max but
you know max is a [ __ ] man well
he said he wants to box now Josie all
there yeah I've heard that but that
doesn't take away from the fact in an
MMA fight right his kicks are one of the
most deadly weapon and weapons in the
sport in his prime man he was so [ __ ]
good but like everyone it's just like
they reach a time o go off can caught
him with a right hand
oh this is a crazy crazy fight man like
you usually don't get these fights 96-95
golovkin power punches landed Wow that's
incredible these guys are just landed -
oh the good left hook - you know Koloff
didn't I mean Canelo rouler is
absolutely a champion and that's the
reason why he keeps firing back and he
won't will and he keeps using good head
movement but there's no doubt about
golovkin is putting it on them one more
round so exciting and then we get to go
to see David branch and Luke Rockhold
how are we so lucky look at this some
Jesus [ __ ] go on yeah I don't know what
that is that's got it all is that it's
gotta be rels can almost mom or
something she was like this is got that
moment come to Jesus moment
um Duff's on just looks so much better
at 170 doesn't he
I missed that fight but he did get an
arm trying I saw this finish put the
smash on Neil Magny put the smash
biggest leg was a big giant he just
looked massive yeah well he's filled in
this is what he his body supposed to
look like he was starving himself
terrible idea I mean he was a beast at
155 from you smashing guys and running
him over but he got to a point where he
really could not make the weight anymore
I mean he was really in real bad shape
we need to wait for Eddie Alvarez he's
thick man so thick dude and at 170 I
mean he's a [ __ ] animal
he kicked Neil Magny legs out from under
him and then he got on top of him and
just put the smooch on him it was just
so high-level how did he get him down
I got down with kick kicked his [ __ ]
leg out from under him and then jumped
on him I just jumped on him dude it was
a beating I mean it was something else
going he has to know he needs a knockout
yeah he's gotta know 12th round ooh
behind the ear in the clinch
look at that uppercut in the clench
pulling the head down going MMA on the
jab of [ __ ] goal of getting so slick
Oh Canelo with the bottom oh [ __ ] hello
with the combo golovkin caught him with
a left hook they could cook goddamn
golovkin has a chin man yeah tell you
that an unbelievable chin him he took
some show [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what a crazy [ __ ] this is on man oh my
god this is amazing
oh and canal LAN to the right hand this
is a crazy fight holy [ __ ] look at that
[ __ ] with a jab in the right hand real
tight in the clinch constant-pressure a
minute 30 to go
does he take over does he take over does
Cannell will have enough to sustain arms
down swinging and missing trying to
catch some blood in there throwing some
punches that just don't have the steam
on him anymore and golovkin and clapper
has to know he's ahead he's still coming
after him yeah he's a [ __ ] spider
dude he's like a spider trying to suck
the blood out of a fly just on you like
almost like just so predator like just
constantly look it's not backing off
he's not boxing this is not a boxing
match he's trying to [ __ ] him up
that's the golovkin style that makes him
so exciting man that's why Mexican
fighters love him they do right yeah
yeah Mexican fight fans are big triple G
fans to the point where his last fight
was um
muchos Gracias he knows man because he
fights like a world-class top of the
food chain Mexican boxer a lot of ways
god damn he's good this is [ __ ]
fantastic yeah those are just hitting
the gloves yeah canal is tired man he's
real tired they're still 20-something to
go but he's still hanging in there man
that's that world champion Hart have
still swinging it doesn't get any better
than this for boxing especially like
after the Conor McGregor Floyd
Mayweather fight this is a fight like
hey
this is how it's done yeah this is the
real deal I mean obviously Floyd did it
how it's supposed to be done but that
wasn't two fighters on the same level
look at this is crazy
these were that's absolutely Glaucus
fine yeah these are both great moments
for box you know the Mayweather McGregor
and this are both really really great
for boxing Brendan Schaub I should say
this before the decision gets announced
said that if golovkin didn't win by some
ungodly lopsided beatdown that he could
lose a decision because of corruption he
goes because that's how boxing rolls and
there's way more money in Canelo winning
so that said now that we know that the
contest sponsor that's true well
apparently the audience is like half
Mexican he's a superstar in Mexico so
just a super silly talking about Canelo
yeah so let's see a Brendan Schaub
predicted this correctly because we
think it has to be gloved in the route
the the unofficial scorecard guy had it
for golovkin by several rounds we think
it was golovkin clearly although
Cannella fought a great fight
have there been bad decision if Canelo
wins have there what was the last time
there was a decision like that Tim
Bradley Manny Pacquiao who who one that
I believe Bradley one but Pacquiao
should have won and then it was like a
boxed him it was worse it was worse if I
remember correctly so what was the look
at that boom boom boom
oh Jesus they're Chanel oh oh my
goodness is the last round that was
Janelle oh just tried to put it to him
and golovkin's like come on come on come
on
I'm from cuts next time oh just boom
over the top
god damn just wore here yeah look at
that she only just paid back every punch
he took in the combination it's a sharp
jab to his gem so snappy okay change it
[Laughter]
give me a guess Eddie Bravo for sure
glove again for sure unless there's
unless there's corruption like crazy to
say that I doubt it their corruption had
we're saying this look at this they got
it 116-112
for golovkin Harrell let them in here
Harold
they gave that letter so love can ran
away with it they gave ten nine
that last fight I mean that last round -
[ __ ] Canelo yeah you know what I
really like I don't know why they did
that I like how these girls just stand
there and smile they're doing really
good job they're always smiling it seems
easy it's hard you got to be frozen and
[ __ ] clapping and it drives me crazy
I hate it I love it I love the their
focus they're focused on not being even
remotely normal this the job their focus
their job is to stand there smile in
some psychotic way if they were a guy
like if they were a guy if you're was if
they hired a guy to stand there in a
nice suit and tie and stand there like
this could you [ __ ] imagine how crazy
would be if you hired guys to stand
behind fighters with giant smiles in
their face and just not especially if
they were in their underwear just
imagine that imagine guys in a speedo
standing there like ripped like holding
it - caught a sign with a big giant
smile at her face that happens on Santa
Monica Boulevard
during a big fight on paper from Eddie
Bravo you silly goose one day when hey
let's hear the volume let's hear it is
this a split decision oh no
told you son oh boy they [ __ ] boxing
[ __ ] stinks told you son mops and Shaw
[ __ ] is a sage Brendan Brendan Schaub
is a safe [ __ ] sting why is he mad
because he knows he knows he got [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] well he's gonna feel
terrible now he knows he got his ass got
to draw it's no way that's how is that a
draw
now it's hold on second he's out gonna
see if he was happy then that would mean
that he thought he lost so that the fact
that he looks pissed that's smart he's
the one I think he's mad because he
didn't win he threw 290 didn't win but
he's definitely mad did he got outbox
and they made it a draw - yeah there's
50 more punches
yeah how the [ __ ] is that a draw it's
not even space it's not even close that
thought our punch is different though
there you go that's the difference -
very much maybe all the higher
percentage I can't stand it
yeah but it's a higher number landed to
114 and 110 and total power punches yeah
yeah I want uh all right yeah absurd
thing though when you're looking at
numbers wise I mean it's one it's one
way of looking at it but like one big
shot that's a power punch and then
another power punch that doesn't do
anything they're both power punches you
know I'm saying like one shot that
really [ __ ] you up and your legs go and
you get wobbly that's a power punch and
another power punch is a shot that lands
in the same spot but doesn't do anything
they're both power what are these colors
mean what have you no I'm saying what is
the blue ear mean oh no no look at the
number of punches that landed on
Canelo's face 109 on his right side and
95 on his left - 10 landed - 127 yeah
big difference in how many landed to the
head get a lot more landed way more hey
mate said only four shots were landed -
Canelo's body that doesn't make any
sense is that what really was said he
says here
see this horn say what happened tonight
good move go right to the Mexican fans
[ __ ] smart move we probably can't
play this without getting yanked off of
youtube so we're gonna go to by the way
first of all that I didn't think that
last fight was uh I mean that last round
was ten nine Canelo no how is he not
[ __ ] angry about this I mean why am i
big drama show to 1980s he retains his
belt so nothing really changes for him
and he gets all that matter your record
your rematch is gonna be insane the
rematch will be insane about those
dollars like 2:19 good job Rendon man
[ __ ] a good call yeah the fighters
were amazing but the organization oh it
just stinks
Brendan nailed it can you hear this are
you are you guys hearing this what no
what am i hearing what he thought you
know if he's not saying I got really
lucky that they gave me that draw I
don't wanna hear what he's saying if he
thinks he wanted he stupid still knows a
great fight amazing I love it I don't
you know I mean I do care but I don't
care I do care that I think that I
thought they're gonna go off in one but
I don't care it's a great fight I like
seeing great fights
I don't decisions mean less to me as I
get older
[Applause]
[Music]